este problema dice en el siguiente
polinomio identifica los términos junto
con el coeficiente y exponente de cada
término muy bien vamos a empezar con los
términos que son simplemente los
sumandos de este polinomio entonces le
voy a poner por aquí términos
términos
términos y tenemos que poner cada uno de
los humanos el primero es 3 x al
cuadrado 3 x al cuadrado
el segundo es menos 8 x menos 8 x y me
vas a decir porque lo pusiste y tiene
menos está pues porque podemos pensar
que estamos sumando menos 8 x vale
entonces para así con todo eso menos y
sería el segundo término y finalmente el
tercer término es 7 entonces esos de ahí
son los términos justo esta expresión se
llama polinomio porque viene de paul y
de muchos términos vale aquí tenemos
tres términos y bueno así cuando están
solitos se les conoce como mono mios
entonces un polinomio tiene varios mono
mios cómo sumandos vale bueno ahora
vamos a pasar a los coeficientes a los
coeficientes y los coeficientes
simplemente son los números que
acompañan a la parte que tiene x por
ejemplo el coeficiente de x al cuadrado
sería 3 porque 3 está multiplicando a
este x al cuadrado
entonces el coeficiente de este primer
término es 3 aquí en el segundo término
el coeficiente es menos 8
porque todo el -8 con con todo y el
menos está multiplicando a la equis y
finalmente en este término de acá pues
parece ser que no tenemos nada con equis
pero para que éste no se quede tan
solito le vamos a poner una equis a la
cero vamos a multiplicar por equis a la
cero y esto simplemente es un 1 y bueno
pensándolo así ahora sí podemos pensar a
este 7 como que acompaña a este término
que tiene equis y por lo tanto aquí en
el término constante el 7 sería el
coeficiente ba entonces para que quede
muy claro déjame indicar que estos de
acá que tus de acá son los coeficientes
pues
sientes
y sí
siente
muy bien entonces esos de ahí 3 8 y 7
son los coeficientes finalmente vamos a
determinar los exponentes pero esto está
sencillo porque ya los tenemos ahí
entonces aquí tenemos un 2 de exponente
aquí no está dibujado el exponente pero
es lo mismo que elevar a la 1 entonces
en este término el exponente sería uno y
finalmente aquí el exponente es cero
entonces déjame indicar que estos de acá
que estos de acá son los exponentes
export
en
muy bien y con esto terminamos el
problema